[Music]
sales of the previously high-flying
Boeing 737 are slumping amid the crisis
surrounding the newest version the max
Boeing the series booked only 36 737
orders and none in the past three months
last year at the mid-year point the
company had secured 296 orders for its
best-selling plane Boeing did get a
boost in June when British Airways
parent IAE said it would buy 200 max
planes though the deal still needs to be
finalized on top of the sales slump
boeing has more than 100 new max jets
sitting undelivered in its facilities
near seattle because the fleet has been
grounded since March more than 300
additional max planes already with
Airlines have also been idled by the
global grounding that's caused huge
disruptions across the aviation
landscape the crisis began last October
when a new max jet crashed on a flight
out of Indonesia it was the first crash
of a max less than five months later
another 737 max crash in Ethiopia a
total of 346 passengers and crew died
aboard those two flights the
similarities between the crashes sparked
safety concerns among regulators and
prompted a global grounding of the max
fleet the impact has reached far beyond
the countries where the planes went down
or Boeing's manufacturing hub in Seattle
for example take Southwest Airlines the
biggest buyer of max planes for now
the airline has struck the model from
flight schedules through October first
the budget airline had received 31 max
planes at the time the fleet was
grounded more were due for delivery over
the summer in response Southwest has had
to cancel flights and juggle schedules
United American and Air Canada are among
the other North American carriers to be
hit American has also had to cancel more
than 100 flights per day because of the
max grounding Air Canada has rented
planes from others including Lufthansa
and Qatar Airways to make up for the
shortage of seats with a max idled and
Iceland air has now struck the plane
from its schedule through October
passengers who are scheduled to fly
aboard Boeing's max fleet also remain
Radl
aiexander de Zuni ACK the
director-general of the world's biggest
airline Association said as much in
early June but the consequences of these
strategy go far beyond the technical
trust in the certification system has
been damaged among regulators between
regulators and the industry and with the
flying public other airlines around the
world that also rely on the Mac's are
scrambling as well many operators told
Boeing they expect to be compensated for
losses from the grounding consider the
case of European travel company tui one
of Europe's biggest max operators it
estimates an earnings hit of more than
330 million dollars this year alone that
bill covers the need to cancel some
flights and the need to rent replacement
aircraft at high cost to get customers
to their vacation hot spots those
involved in making the max also are
being impacted Boeing in April said it
would keep building 737s though at a
slower pace rather and cranking out 50
to 737s a month the company announced it
would build only 42 a month Boeing's
vast max supply chain also is grappling
with the turmoil Spirit AeroSystems said
some of its employees have been put on
shorter work weeks reducing their pay
investors haven't been immune either
after delivering a record number of
planes in 2018 bond shares reached a
record high early this year but since
then the aerospace Giants stock has
slumped also seeing their investments
fall our Spirit AeroSystems shareholders
the stock has declined about 25 percent
since March
earlier this year Boeing was hoping to
get the max fixed quickly but new
concerns with the plane systems have led
to delays for example in June an FAA
pilot found a new potential problem with
the 737 Max's flight control system
Boeing now says it won't submit its max
fix to the FA until September the FAA
and other regulators have not said when
they in turn may clear the plane to
resume carrying passengers until that
happens Boeing and its partners will
have to deal with the massive
all left by the beleaguered 737 max
[Music]